[Music]
you're joining us now is U.S President
Joe Biden gets set to deliver his second
State of the Union Address all eyes are
on Capitol Hill as Biden is expected to
speak to a deeply divided Congress about
economic uncertainty and policing reform
the war in Ukraine and tensions with
China are also expected to be on the
agenda the Biden goes into the speech
with a flagging approval rating of 42
percent one of the worst ever second
year approval ratings for U.S president
let's now go live to our White House
correspondent Kimberly halket she's
there at Capitol Hill that's so Kimberly
we're expecting a speech with
unavoidable international issues but
he's very much hoping to woo a domestic
U.S audience with a bulk of his address
isn't he
yeah there's no question that this is a
pivotal speech for Joe Biden and this is
the president's second State of the
Union Address but there's a key
difference this time and that key
difference is that this time he speaks
to a divided Congress previously Joe
Biden's Democrats controlled both the
House of Representatives as well as the
U.S Senate this time that is not the
case the House of Representatives
controlled by opposition Republicans and
so he has that backdrop he also has the
backdrop of poll numbers which are among
the lowest of his presidency and so he
makes a pitch to the American public for
another term in office in many cases
this is a de facto pitch if you will to
the American public for another term in
the White House and so the U.S president
is not only going to be throughout the
speech highlighting the successes that
he sees of the past two years but also
making the case for another four now as
we watch these pictures you've seen the
members of the cabinet they've been
filing into the House of Representatives
already we've seen the members of the
House of Representatives seated as well
as the members of Congress from the U.S
Senate seated there's also you'll see on
the left of your screen there the
members of the Judiciary that's the
members of the Supreme Court what we're
waiting for now is the sergeant of arms
to bring in or announce the arrival of
U.S President Joe Biden you can also see
there the first lady Dr Jill Biden as
well as vice president Kamala Harris's
husband as well the first gentleman as
well he is seated there and also in the
gallery there are some very pivotal
guests that often give us a bit of a
road map to the president's priorities
that he'll be laying out in the speech
we know for example that Tyree Nichols
parents you'll remember that Tyree
Nichols was the man that was killed in
that very graphic video that came out of
Memphis he was the victim of police
brutality of those five Memphis police
officers accompanying Dr Jill Biden will
be his stepfather as well as his mother
as the President addresses police reform
in his speech we also know that
accompanying the first lady will be the
Ukraine ambassador to the United States
as the president once again underscores
the importance of U.S support for
Ukraine and we also know that there will
be as well activism that will be
addressed and it looks like the
president is about to come in so let's
listen as Dr rather Joe Biden walks in
and greets those that are gathered in
the chamber
[Applause]
as we see him coming in here very much a
pitch to a domestic audience but as you
say he can't ignore the ongoing war in
Ukraine and issues regarding China can
he
no and that's definitely something that
he will have to address and of course uh
he will also we expect to address the
earthquake that has just taken place and
the the thousands of lives that have
been lost recently in turkey and in
Syria we expect that he is also going to
talk about uh just that tragedy in the
U.S commitment to rebuilding there we
expect that he will once again pledge
for ongoing commitments for
international support
continuing in Ukraine and appeal to U.S
partners and allies and as well we
expect that he will potentially given
the incident of the Chinese spy balloon
that has drifted over the United States
in the last week he may even have some
harsh words for China we know in
previous year he only mentioned China
about three times in his State at the
union speech and many are watching to
see if he will mention it more or this
time around and we should also point out
that the back at the of the chamber
there you see the vice president as well
as uh the house Speaker that's vice
president Kamala Harris as well as the
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy once the
president gets to the podium he will
turn around and he will hand each of
them a copy of his speech you will
remember perhaps some of our viewers
will remember in previous years when
Donald Trump was president that house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi famously ripped up
Donald Trump's speech we don't expect
that to be the case this time around but
we watch very carefully to see what kind
of body language there will be as there
is that interaction you have to remember
that Kevin McCarthy is a republican Joe
Biden is a Democrat uh and you have to
also remember that Joe Biden was once a
U.S senator so he is very comfortable on
Capitol Hill he has been in this chamber
in the audience many many times watching
the State of Union address now of course
he gives this address as a president and
we know
we know the president will be speaking
about a number of key issues not only
will he be highlighting his successes a
couple of legislative agenda items that
he believes are successful for example
his infrastructure law as well as
combating inflation he's going to talk
about the very successful low
unemployment numbers some of the lowest
in a half century but we also know the
president's going to talk to Congress
about spending more money to help
improve ordinary Americans lives he's
going to call on Congress to spend more
on cancer research and things like
mental health in combating the opioid
Addiction in the United States as well
as combating the high suicide rate when
it comes to Veterans so you can see
there the president continuing to make
his way through the crowd as he makes
his way towards the podium
the president is going to talk a lot
about the economy again the president is
still dealing with some very high
inflation numbers and this is kind of
the Crux of one of the president's
problems when it comes to his low
approval ratings the fact that ordinary
Americans are still struggling to pay
some very high prices so we watch very
carefully to see what the president will
say about that his approaching his feet
shaking hands with the house speaker and
the vice president soon he'll hand them
a copy of the speech and then he will
is about to deliberate now let's take a
listen
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
members of Congress I have the high
privilege and distinct honor to present
to you the president of the United
States
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
thank you you can smile it's okay
thank you thank you thank you
thank you please
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Madam vice president
our first lady and second gentleman good
to see you guys up there
members of Congress
by the way chief justice I may need a
court order she gets to go to the
game tomorrow next week I have to stay
home
got to work something out here members
of the cabinet leaders of our military
chief justice associate Justice and
retired Justice Supreme Court and to you
my fellow Americans
you know I start tonight by
congratulating 118th Congress the new
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
speaker I don't want to ruin your
reputation but I look forward to working
with you
the house Democrats the first
African-American minority leader in
history Hakeem Jeffries
[Applause]
if you want us by the fact I campaigned
for him huh
congratulations the longest serving
leader in the history of the United
States Senate Mitch McConnell where are
you Mitch
and congratulations to Chuck Schumer
another uh you know another term is was
Senate minority leader uh you know I
think you uh only this time you have a
slightly bigger majority Mr leader
you're the majority leader
about that much bigger
well I tell you what I want to give
special a special recognition to someone
who I think is going to be considered
the greatest speaker in the history of
the House of Representative Nancy Pelosi
folks the story of America is a story of
progress and resilience
of always moving forward of never ever
giving up
is a story unique among all nations
we're the only country that has emerged
from every crisis we've ever entered
stronger than we got into it look folks
that's what we're doing again
two years ago the economy was Reeling I
stand here tonight after we've created
with the help of many people in this
room
12 million new jobs more jobs created in
two years than any president's created
in four years because of you all because
of the American people
two years ago
and two years ago
covet had shut down our businesses were
closed our schools were robbed of so
much and today covert no longer controls
Our Lives
and two years ago democracy faced his
greatest threats of the Civil War and
today though bruised our democracy
remains unbowed and Unbroken
As We Gather here tonight
we're writing the next chapter the Great
American story a story of progress and
resilience
when world leaders asked me to Define
America and they do believe it or not
exciting to find it in one word and I
mean this possibilities we don't think
anything is beyond our capacity
everything is a possibility
you know we're often told that Democrats
and Republicans can't work together but
over the past two years we've proved the
cynics and naysayers wrong
yes we disagreed plenty and yes there
were times when Democrats went alone
but time and again Democrats and
Republicans came together came together
to defend us stronger and safer Europe
it came together to pass one in the one
in a generation once in generation
infrastructure law Building Bridges
connecting our nation and our people we
came together to pass the most
significant law ever helping victims
expose the toxic burn pits and in fact
is important
in fact
I signed over 300
bipartisan pieces of legislation since
becoming president from reauthorizing
the violence against women act the
Electoral count Reform Act the respect
for marriage act that protects the right
to marry the person you love and to my
Republican friends we could work
together the last Congress there's no
reason we can't work together and find
consensus on important things in this
Congress as well
I think
you all are as informed as I am but I
think the people sent us a clear message
fighting for the sake of fighting power
for the sake of power Conflict for the
sake of conflict gets us nowhere
that's always been my vision of our
country and I know it's many of yours to
restore the soul of this nation to
rebuild the backbone of America
America's middle class and to unite the
country
we've been sent here to finish the job
in my view
for decades the middle class has been
hollowed out and more than and not know
one Administration but for a long time
too many good paying manufacturing jobs
move overseas factories closed down once
thriving cities and towns that many of
you represent became Shadows of what
they used to be
along the way something else we lost
Pride our sense of self-worth
I ran for president to fundamentally
change things to make sure our economy
works for everyone so we can all feel
that pride in what we do
to build an economy from the bottom up
in the middle out
not from the top down because when the
middle class does well the poor have a
ladder up and the wealthy still do very
well we all do well
I know a lot of you always kidding me
for always quoting my dad but my dad
used to say Joey and jobs about a lot
more than a paycheck because you really
would say this it's about a lot more
than a paycheck it's about your dignity
it's about respect it's about being able
to look your kid in the eye and say
honey it's gonna be okay and mean it
folks
so let's look at the results
we're not finished yet by any stretchy
imagination but unemployment rate is at
3.4 percent a 50-year low
[Music]
record
the near record unemployment
near record unemployment for Black and
Hispanic workers we've already created
your help eight hundred thousand good
paying manufacturing jobs the fastest
growth in 40 years
thank you
and where is it written
where is it written that America can't
lead the world in manufacturing I don't
know where that's written
for too many decades we imported
projects and exported jobs
now thanks to what you've all done we're
exporting American products and creating
American jobs
folks
inflation
inflation has been a global problem
because the pandemic disrupted our
supply chains and Putin's unfair and
brutal war in Ukraine disrupted energy
supplies as well as Food Supplies
blocking all that grain in Ukraine but
we're a better position than any country
on Earth right now but we have more to
do but here at home inflation is coming
down here at home gas prices are down a
dollar fifty from their Peak
food inflation is coming down not fast
enough but coming down inflation is
falling every month for the last six
months or take-home pay has gone up
additionally over the last two years a
record 10 million Americans apply to
start new businesses 10 million
and by the way
every time
every time someone starts in small
businesses an act of Hope
and Madam vice president I want to thank
you for leading that effort to ensure
the small businesses have access to
Capital
and the historic laws we enacted that
are going to just come into being
this year
I shared with you a story
of American genius and possibilities
semiconductors
small computer chips the size of a
fingerprint that power everything from
cell phones to Automobiles and so much
more
these chips were invented in America
let's get that straight they were
invented in America
because we used to make 40 of the
world's chips
in the last several decades we lost our
Edge we're down only producing 10
percent
we all saw what happened during the
pandemic when chip factories shut down
overseas today's automobiles need 3 000
chips each of those automobiles
but American automobiles couldn't make
enough cars because there weren't enough
chips car prices went up people got laid
off so did everything from refrigerators
to cell phones we can never let that
happen again that's why
that's why we came together to pass the
bipartisan chips and science Act
folks
I know I've been criticized for saying
this but I'm not changing my view we're
going to make sure the supply chain for
America begins in America the supply
chain begins in America
we've already created
you've already created
800 000 new manufacturing jobs without
this law before the law get kicks in
with this new law we're going to create
hundreds of thousands of new jobs across
the country I mean all across the
country throughout not just the coast
but through the middle of the country as
well that's going to come from companies
that have announced more than 300
billion dollars in investment in
American manufacturing over the next few
years
outside of Columbus Ohio Intel is
building semiconductor factories on a
thousand acres literally a Field of
Dreams it's going to create ten thousand
jobs at one investment
seven thousand construction jobs
three thousand jobs in those factories
once they're finished they call them
factors
jobs paying an average of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a year and many
do not require a college degree
Josh
because we work together these jobs
where people don't have to leave home to
search for opportunity it's just getting
started
think about the new homes the small
businesses the big the medium-sized
businesses so much more that's going to
be needed to support those 3000 those 3
000 permanent jobs
and the factors that are going to be
built
talk to Mayors and governors Democrats
and Republicans and they'll tell you
what this means for their communities
we're seeing these Field of Dreams
transform to the heartland
but to maintain the strongest economy in
the world we need the best
infrastructure in the world
folks
as you all know
we used to be number one in the world in
infrastructure
we've sunk the 13th in the world the
United States of America
13th in the world and infrastructure
modern infrastructure
but now we're coming back because we
came together and passed the bipartisan
infrastructure law the largest
investment infrastructure since
President Eisenhower's interstate
highway system
and folks
already we've funded over 20 000
projects including major airports from
Boston to Atlanta to Portland projects
are going to put thousands of people to
work rebuilding our highways our bridges
our railroads our tunnels ports airports
clean water high-speed internet all
across America Urban rural tribal and
folks we're just getting started we're
just getting started
and I mean you sincerely
I want to thank my Republican friends
who voted for the law
and my Republican friends who voted
against it as well
but I'm still I I still get asked to
fund the projects in those districts as
well but don't worry
I promised I'd be a president for all
Americans we'll fund these projects and
I'll see you at the groundbreaking
[Applause]
look
this law
this law will further unite all of
America projects like Brent spend bridge
in Kentucky over the Ohio river built 60
years ago badly needed repairs one of
the nation's most congested Freight
routes carrying two billion dollars
worth of freight every single day across
the Ohio River and folks I've been
talking about fixing it for decades but
we're really finally going to get it
done
I went there last month with Democrats
and Republicans and from both states to
deliver a commitment of 1.6 billion
dollars for this project
while I was
met a young
woman who's here tonight I don't know
where Sarah is the chef in the Box I
don't know Sarah how are you
well Sarah for 30 years
for 30 years
I learned she told me she'd been a proud
member of the Iron Workers Local 44
known as
Nomads the Cowboys in the sky
the folks who built
built Cincinnati skyline Sheriff said
she can't wait to be 10 stories above
the Ohio River Building that new bridge
God bless her
that's pride and that's we're also
building we're building back Pride
look we're also replacing poisonous lead
pipes that go into 10 million homes in
America
400 000 school and Child Care Centers so
every child in America
every child American drink the water
instead of having permanent damage to
their brain
look
we're making sure
that every community
every community in America has access to
Affordable high-speed internet no parent
should have to drive by McDonald's
parking lot to help her do their farm
work online or their kids which many
thousands were doing across the country
and when we do these projects
and again I get criticize this if I make
no excuses for it we're going to buy
American we're going to buy America
folks
and it's totally is totally consistent
with International Trade rules
buy America has been the law since 1933
but for too long past administration is
Democrat and Republican have fought to
get around it not anymore
tonight I'm announcing new standards
require all construction materials used
in federal infrastructure projects to be
made in America
I mean it
Lumber
glass drywall fiber optic cable and I
might watch American roads Bridges
American highways are going to be made
with American Products as well folks
my economic plan is about investing in
places and people that have been
forgotten
so many of you listen to me tonight
I know you feel it
so many of you felt like you've just
simply been forgotten
the past four decades
too many people have been left behind
and treated like they're invisible
maybe that's you watching from home
remember the jobs that went away you
remember them don't you
the folks at home remember them
you wonder whether the path even exists
anymore for your children to get ahead
without having to move away
well that's why I get that
that's why we're building an economy
where no one's left behind
jobs are coming back
pride is coming back
because choices we made in the last
several years
you know
this is my view of blue collar blueprint
to rebuild America make a real
difference in your lives at home
for example
too many of you
lay in bed at night like my dad did
staring at the ceiling wondering
wouldn't God names happens if your
spouse gets cancer
or your child gets deadly ill
or something happens to you
what are you going to get money to pay
for those medical bills or you're going
to have to sell the house or try to get
a second mortgage on it
I get it I get it
the inflation reduction act that I
signed into law
we're taking on powerful interest to
bring health care costs down
so you can sleep better at night
with more security
you know we pay more for prescription
drugs than any nation in the world let
me say it again we pay more for
prescription drugs than any major Nation
on Earth
for example
one in ten Americans has diabetes many
of you in this chamber do and then the
audience
but every day Millions need insulin to
control their diabetes
so they can literally stay alive
insulin's been around for over a hundred
years
a guy who invented didn't even patent it
because he wanted to be available for
everyone
it costs the drug companies roughly ten
dollars a vial to make that insulin
packaging and all you may get up to
thirteen dollars
but big Pharma has been unfairly
charging people hundreds of dollars four
to five hundred dollars a month making
record profits
not anymore
so many so many things that we did are
only now coming to fruition
we said we were doing this and we said
we passed the law to do it but people
didn't know because the law didn't take
effect until January 1 of this year
we capped the cost of insulin at 35 a
month for seniors on Medicare
people to just find
it I'm sure you're getting the same
calls I'm getting
look there are millions of other
Americans
who do not or are not on Medicare
including 200 000 young people with type
1 diabetes in these needless insulin to
stay alive
it's finished the job this time let's
cap the cost events for everybody at 35
dollars
folks
the big Farmer's still going to do very
well I promise you all I promise you
they're going to do very well
this law saw this law also caps and
won't go into effect on the 2025
costs out-of-pocket drug costs for
seniors on Medicare at a maximum of two
thousand dollars a year you don't have
to pay more than two thousand dollars no
matter how much your drug costs are
because you know why you all know it
many of you like many of my family have
cancer
you know the drugs can range from 10 11
14 15
000 for the Cancer drugs
the drug prices rise faster than
inflation drug companies are going to
have to pay Medicare back the difference
we're finally
we're finally giving Medicare the power
to negotiate drug prices
bringing down
bringing down prescription drug costs
doesn't just save seniors money
cuts the federal deficit by billions of
dollars
by hundreds of billions of dollars
because these prescription drugs
are drugs purchased by Medicare to make
keep their commitment to the seniors
well guess what
instead of paying four or five hundred
bucks a month you're paying 15. that's a
lot of savings for the federal
government
and by the way why would we want that
now some members here are threatening
and I know it's not an official party
position so I'm not I'm going to
exaggerate
but certainly to repeal the inflation
reduction Act
as my coach
that's okay that's fair
as my football coach used to say lots of
luck in your senior year
make no mistake
if you try anything to raise the cost of
producing jobs I will veto it
look
I'm pleased to say the more Americans
out for the health insurance now than
ever in history a record 16 million
people are enrolled in the Affordable
Care Act and thanks
thanks for the watch sign last year
saving millions of saving 800 a year on
their premiums by the way that law was
written
and the benefit expires in 2025
so my plea to some of you at least in
this audience let's finish the job and
make these savings permanent
expand coverage on Medicaid
look
the inflation reduction Act is also the
most significant investment ever in
climate change
lower utility bill
y bill created American jobs leading the
world to a clean energy future I visited
the devastating aftermath of record
floods droughts storms and wildfires
from Arizona New Mexico to all the way
up to the Canadian border
more Timber has been burned as I've
observed from helicopters than the
entire state of Missouri
and we don't have global warming not a
problem
in addition to emergency recovery from
Puerto Rico to Florida to Idaho we're
rebuilding for the long term
new electric grids that are able to
weather major storms and not prevent
those forest fires roads and Water
Systems withstand the next big flood
clean energy to cut pollution and create
jobs and communities often left behind
we're going to build 500 000 electric
vehicle charging stations installed
that'll cross the country by tens of
thousands of IBEW workers
and
we're helping families save more than a
thousand dollars a year with tax credits
to purchase electric vehicles and
efficient and efficient appliances
energy efficient appliances
historic conservation efforts to be
responsible stewards of our land
let's face reality
the climate crisis doesn't care if
you're in a red or blue state
it's an existential threat
we have an obligation not to ourselves
but our children or grandchildren to
confront it
I'm proud of how the how America at last
is stepping up to the challenge
we're still going to need oil and gas
for a while
but guess what no we do
but there's so much more to do
we got to finish the job
we pay for these investments in our
future by finally making the wealthiest
and biggest corporations begin to pay
their fair share
just began
look I'm a capitalist
I'm a capitalist but pay your fair share
I think a lot of you at home a lot of
you at home agree with me and many
people that you know
the tax system is not fair it is not
fair
the idea
that in 2020
55 of the largest corporations in
America the fortune 500. made 40 billion
dollars in profits and paid zero in
federal taxes zero
folks simply not fair
but now because of the law I signed
billion dollar companies have to pay a
minimum of 15 God loved them
15 percent
that's less than the nurse pays
let me be crystal clear I said at the
very beginning under my plans as long as
I'm president nobody earning less than
four hundred thousand dollars will pay
an additional penny in taxes nobody not
one penny
well let's finish the job there's more
to do
we have to reward work not just wealth
passed my proposal for the billionaire
minimum tax
you know there's a thousand billionaires
in America it's up from about 600 in the
beginning of June but no billionaire
should be paying a lower tax rate than
the school teacher or firefighter
think about it
I mean look
I know you aren't enthusiastic about
that but think about it
think about it
have you noticed Big Oil just reported
as profits record profits
last year they made
200 billion dollars in the midst of a
global energy crisis
I think it's outrageous
why they invested too little of that
profit increased domestic production
and when I talked to a couple of them
they say we're afraid you're going to
shut down all the oil wells and all the
oil refineries anyway so why should we
invest in them I said we're going to
need oil for at least another decade
and that's going to exceed
and beyond that we're gonna need it
production
if they had in fact invested in the
production to keep gas prices down
instead they use the record profits to
buy back their own stock
rewarding the CEOs and shareholders
corporations ought to do the right thing
that's why I propose we quadruple the
tax on corporate stock BuyBacks and
occurs long long-term Investments
they'll still make considerable profit
let's finish the job and close the
loophole to allow very wealthy to avoid
paying their taxes instead of cutting
the number of orders for wealthy
taxpayers I just signed the law to
reduce the deficit by 114 billion
dollars by cracking down on Wealthy tax
sheets
that's being fiscally responsible
in the last two years
my Administration has cut the deficit
why more than
1.7 trillion dollars
the largest deficit reduction in
American history
under the previous administration the
American deficit went up four years in a
row
because those record deficits no
president added more than the national
debt
in any four years than my predecessor
nearly 25 percent of the entire national
debt that took over 200 years to
accumulate was added by just one
Administration alone the last one
they're the facts check it out
check it out
[Applause]
how did Congress respond to that debt
they did the right thing they left the
debt ceiling three times without
preconditions or crisis
they paid American bills to prevent an
economic disaster in the country
so tonight I'm asking the Congress to
follow suit
let's commit here tonight to the
full-fated credit of the United States
of America will never ever be questioned
so my many some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage I get
it unless I agree to their economic
plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
I'll give you a copy of The Proposal
[Applause]
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you now I tell you
I enjoy conversion
Congress doesn't keep the programs the
way they are they'd go away other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look
folks
the ideas
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't
respond
folks
so folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is also off the
books now right
all right
we got unanimity
Social Security Medicare Lifeline for
millions of seniors Americans have to
pay into them from the very first
paycheck they started so tonight let's
all agree and apparently are let's stand
up for seniors
stand up and show them
will not cuts off Securities we will not
cut Medicare
those benefits belong to the American
people they earned it if anyone tries to
cut Social Security which apparently no
one's going to do
and if anyone tries to stop Medicare
I'll stop them I'll veto it
and look I'm not going to allow them to
take away be taken away not today not
tomorrow not ever but apparently it's
not going to be a problem
next month
when I offered my fiscal plan I asked my
Republican friends to lay down their
plan as well
I really mean it let's sit down together
and discuss our mutual plans together
let's do that
I can tell you
plan I'm going to show he's going to cut
the deficit by another two trillion
dollars
and I won't cut a single bit of Medicare
or Social Security in fact we're going
to extend the Medicare trust fund at
least two decades because that's going
to be the next argument how do we make
keep it solvent right
well we'll not raise tax anyone making
under 400 Grand but
we'll pay for it the way we talked about
by making sure that the wealthy and big
corporations pay their fair share look
look here's the deal
they're not just taking advantage of the
tax code they're taking advantage you
the American Consumer here's my message
to all of you out there I have your back
we're already preventing Americans and
receiving surprise medical bills
stopping one billion dollar surprise
bills per month so far
for protecting
seniors life savings
by cracking down in nursing homes that
commit fraud and danger patient safety
prescribe drugs that are not needed
millions of Americans can now save
thousands of dollars because they can
finally get a hearing aid over the
counter without a prescription
look
capitalism
without competition is not capitalism
it's extortion
is exploitation
last year I cracked down with the help
of many of you on foreign shipping
companies that were making you pay
higher prices for every good coming in
the country I signed a bipartisan bill
of cut shipping costs by 90 percent
helping American farmers businessmen and
consumers let's finish the job
pass the bipartisan legislation of
strength and strengthen and Trust
enforcement and forbid and prevent big
online platforms giving their own
products an unfair advantage
my Administration is also taking on junk
fees those hidden surcharges too many
companies use to make you pay more for
example we're making Airlines show you
the full ticket price up front
refund your money if your flight is
canceled or delayed we reduce
exorbitant Bank overdrafts by Saving
consumers more than one billion dollars
a year
for cutting credit card late fees by 75
percent from thirty dollars to eight
dollars
look
look junk fees
may not matter to very wealthy but they
matter to most other folks in homes like
the one I grew up in like many of you
did they add up to hundreds of dollars a
month
they make it harder for you to pay your
bills and afford that family trip
I know how unfair it feels when a
company overcharges you and gets away
with it not anymore
we've written a bill to stop it all it's
called the junk fee prevention Act
we're going to ban surprise Resort fees
that hotels charge on your bill those
fees can cost up to ninety dollars a
night in hotels that aren't even resorts
foreign
the idea that cable internet and cell
phone companies can charge you 200 or
more if you decide to switch another
provider give me a break
we can stop service fees on tickets to
concerts and sporting events and make
companies as close all the fees up front
and will prohibit Airlines from charging
50 round trip for family just to be able
to sit together
baggies fees are bad enough Airlines
can't treat your child like a piece of
baggage
America
's are being played for suckers
surpass
the junk food prevention act so
companies stop ripping us off
for too long
workers have been getting stiffed but
not anymore we're getting we're
beginning to restore the Dignity of work
for example
I I should have known this but I didn't
until two years ago
30 million workers have to sign
non-compete agreements
with the jobs they take 30 million
so a cashier
at a burger place can't walk across town
and take the same job at another burger
place and make a few bucks more and just
change but they just changed it because
we exposed it
that was part of the deal guys look it
up
but not anymore
we're Banning those agreements so
companies have to compete for workers
and pay them what they're worth
and I must tell you
which is bound to get a response from my
friends on my left but the right
I'm so sick and tired of companies
breaking the law by preventing workers
from organizing pass the pro Act
because business had a right
workers have a right to form a union
let's guarantee all workers have a
living wage
let's make sure working parents can
afford to raise a family with sick days
Paid Family Medical Leave affordable
child care
millions of more people have gone stay
at work and let's restore the full child
tax credit
which gave tens of millions of parents a
breeding room and cut child poverty in
half to the lowest level in history and
by the way we do all these things we
increase productivity we increase
economic growth so let's finish the job
and get more families access to
affordable quality housing let's get
seniors who want to stay in their homes
the care they need to do so
let's get more breathing room to
millions of family caregivers looking
after their loved ones
past my plan so we get seniors and
people with disabilities the home care
and services they need
and support
the workers who are doing God's work
these plans are fully paid for and we
can afford to do them
restoring the Dignity of work means
making education an affordable ticket to
the middle class
you know when we made public education
12 years of a universal in the last
century
we made the best educated best paid we
became the best educated best paid
nation in the world
the rest of us caught up
it's caught up
Jill my wife who teaches full time has
an expression
I hope I get it right kid
any nation that out educates us is going
to out-compete us
Indian Asian out education can now
compete us folks we all know 12 years of
education is not enough to win the
economic competition of 21st century
if you want to have the best educated
Workforce let's finish the job
by providing access to preschool for
three to four years old
studies show that children to go to
preschool are nearly 50 percent more
likely to finish high school and go on
to earn a two or four year degree no
matter their background they came from
let's get Public School teachers a raise
[Applause]
for making progress
by reducing student debt increasing Pell
Grants for working in Middle Class
families let's finish the job
and connect students to career
opportunities starting in high school
provide access to two years of Community
College the best career training in
America in addition to being a pathway
to a four-year degree
let's offer every American a path to a
good tree whether they go to college or
not
folks
[Applause]
folks in the midst of the kova crisis
when schools were closed
and we were shutting down everything
let's recognize how far we came in the
fight against the pandemic itself
while the virus is not gone thanks to
the resilience of the American people
and the Ingenuity of Medicine
we've broken the cover grip on us
covered deaths were down by 90 percent
we've saved millions of lives and opened
up
our country we opened our country back
up and soon we'll end the public health
emergency
but
that's called a public health emergency
but we'll remember the toll and pain is
never going to go away
more than a million Americans lost their
lives to covet a million
families grieving
children orphaned
Empty Chairs the dining room table
constantly reminding you
and she used to sit there
remembering them
we remain vigilant
we still need to monitor dozens of
variants and support new vaccines and
treatments so Congress needs to fund
these efforts and keep America safe
and as we emerge from this crisis
stronger
we're also got to double down on
Prosecuting criminals who stole relief
money meant to keep workers in small
businesses
before I came to office you remember
during that campaign the big issue was
about inspector generals
who would protect taxpayers dollars from
her sideline
they were fired
many people said we don't need them
and fraud became rampant
last year I told you the Watchdogs are
back
since then since then we've covered
billions of taxpayers dollars now let's
triple the anti-fraud strike force going
after these criminals double the statute
of limitations on these crimes and crack
down on identity fraud by criminal
syndicates stealing billions of dollars
billions of dollars from the American
people
and the data showed that for every
dollar we put in the fighting fraud the
tax rate get back at least 10 times as
much it matters it matters
look
cover left his scars
like to spike in violent crime in 2020.
the first year of the pandemic
we have an obligation to make sure all
people are safe
Public Safety depends on public trust as
all of us know
but too often that trust is violated
join us tonight are the parents of Tyree
Nichols
welcome
[Applause]
I had to bury Tyree last week
as many of you personally know there's
no words to describe the hard acre brief
of losing the child
but imagine
if you lost that child at the hands of
the law
imagine
having to worry whether your son or
daughter came home from walking down the
street
playing in the park or just driving a
car
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk the brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley my children
I never had to have a talk with them
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over
turn their interior lights on right away
don't reach for your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
here's what tyree's mother shared with
me when I spoke to her
when I asked her how she finds the
courage to carry on and speak out
the faith of God she said her son was
quote a beautiful soul
and something good will come of this
imagine how much courage and carry that
takes
it's up to us to all of us
we all want the same thing
neighborhoods free of violence law
enforcement law enforcement earned the
community's trust
just as every cop when they pin on that
badge in the morning has a right to be
able to go home at night
so does everybody else out there
our children have a right to come home
safely
equal protection under the law is a
covenant
we have with each other in America
we know
police officers put their lives on the
line every single night and day
and we know we ask them in many cases to
do too much to be counselors social
workers psychologists responding to drug
overdoses mental health crises and so
much more
in one sense we asked much too much of
them
I know most cops and their families are
good decent honorable people the vast
majority
if they risk
and they risk their lives
every time they put that shield on
but what happened to Tyree in Memphis
happens too often
we have to do better
give law enforcement the real training
they need
hold them to higher standards
help them succeed in keeping us safe
we also need more first respondents and
professionals to address the growing
mental health substance abuse challenges
more research
[Applause]
more investment in housing education and
job training
all this can help prevent violence in
the first place
when police officers
or police departments violate the public
Trust they must be held accountable
with the support
for the support
of the families and victims
civil rights groups and law enforcement
I signed an executive order for all
federal officers Banning chokeholds
restricting no knock warrants another
key elements of the George Floyd Act
let's commit ourselves to make the words
of Tyler's mom true
something good must come from this
something good
and all of us
all of us
[Applause]
folks it's difficult but it's simple all
of us in the chain in this chamber we
need to rise to this moment
we can't turn away
let's do what we know in our hearts
that we need to do
let's come together to finish the job on
police reform
do something do something
that was The Plea of parents who lost
their children Uvalde I met with every
one of them
do something about gun violence
thank God
thank God we did
passing the most sweeping gun safety law
three decades
that includes things like
but the majority of responsible gun
owners already support
enhanced background checks for 18 to 21
years old red flag laws keeping guns out
of the hands of people are a danger to
themselves and others
but we know our work is not done
join us tonight is Brandon say a 26 year
old hero Brandon put his college dreams
on hold to beat his mom's side his mom's
side when she was dying from cancer
Brandon
Brandon not works at the dance studio
started by his grandparents
two weeks ago
there are no Lunar New Year celebrations
you heard the studio door closed and you
saw a man standing there pointing
semi-automatic pistol at him
he thought he was going to die
but he thought about the people inside
and that instant he found the courage to
act and wrestle the semi-automatic
pistol away from the gunman who had
already killed 11 people in another
Dance Studio
11.
he saved lives
it's time we do the same band assault
weapons now
saying them now
once and for all
I let the fight to do that in 1994.
in
10 years that band was law mass
shootings went down after he let it
expire in the Republican Administration
mass shootings tripled let's finish the
job and ban these assault weapons
and let's also come together on
immigration
make it a bipartisan issue once again
we know we now have a record number of
personnel working to secure the Border
resting 8 000 human Smugglers seizing
over 23 000 pounds of fentanyl in just
the last several months
we've launched a new border plan last
month
unlawful migration from Cuba Haiti
Nicaragua and Venezuela has come down 97
as a consequence of that
but American Border problems won't be
fixed until Congress Acts if we don't
pass my comprehensive immigration reform
at least passed my plan to provide the
equipment and officers to secure the
Border
and a pathway to citizenship for
dreamers those on temporary status Farm
Workers essential workers
here in the people's house
it's our duty to protect all the
people's rights and freedoms
Congress must restore the right and the
Congress must restore the right
that was taken away
in Roe v Wade and protect Roe v Wade
give everyone an apostle Road
the vice president and I are doing
everything
exact access to reproduction health care
we Safeguard patient safety but already
more than a dozen states are enforcing
extreme abortion bans make no mistake
about it Congress passes a national ban
I will veto it
but let's
also it's also
quality act with your LPG lgbtq
Americans especially transgender young
people can live with safety and dignity
our strength
our strength is not just the example of
our power but the power of our example
let's remember the world's watching
I spoke in this chamber one year ago
just days after Vladimir Putin Unleashed
his brutal attack against Ukraine a
murderous assault evoking images of
death and destruction Europe suffered in
World War II
Putin's Invasion has been a test
for the ages test for America the test
for the world
would we stand for the most basic of
principles
we stand for sovereignty we stand for
the right of people to live free of
tyranny
will we stand for the defense of
democracy
for such defense matters to us because
it keeps peace and prevents Open Season
I would be aggressive and threatens our
prosperity
one year later we know the answer yes we
would and we did we did
and together
we did what America always does at our
best we LED
we United NATO
we build a global coalition
we stood against Putin's aggression
we stood with Ukrainian people to deny
we're once again joined by ukrainian's
ambassador to the United States she
represents not her and just our nation
but the courage of her People ambassador
as our ambassador is here United we're
in uniting our support of your country
when you stand so we can all take a look
at you
because we're going to stand with you
[Applause]
as long as it takes
our nation is working for more freedom
more dignity more more peace not just in
Europe but everywhere
before I came to office the story was
about how the People's Republic of China
was increasing its power
and America is failing in the world
not anymore
we made clear and I made my personal
conversation which have been many with
President XI and we seek competition not
conflict
but I will make no apologies
that we're investing and to make America
stronger investing in American
innovation and Industry that will Define
the future that China intends to be
dominating
investing in our alliances and working
with our allies to protect Advanced
Technologies so they will not be used
against us modernizing our military to
safeguard stability and determine to
deter aggression today we're the
strongest position in decades to compete
with China or anyone else in the world
anywhere else in the world
we're not committed
I'm committed to work with China where
we can advance American interest and
benefit the world but make no mistake
about it
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did
look
let's be clear when in the competition
should you nine all of us
we Face serious challenges across the
world
but in the past two years democracies
have become stronger and not weaker
autocracy has grown weaker not stronger
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
America's rallying the world to meet
those challenges from climate to Global
Health to food insecurity to terrorism
to territorial aggression
allies are stepping up spending more and
doing more
look
the bridges were forming between
partners in the Pacific and those in the
Atlantic
and those who bet against America are
learning how wrong they are it's never
ever been a good bet to bet against
America never
wow
when I came to office most assured the
bipartisanship assumed was impossible
I never believed it that's why a year
ago I offered a Unity agenda to the
nation as I stood here we made real
progress together
we passed the law and make it easy for
doctors to prescribe effective
treatments for opioid addiction
we passed
the gun safety law making historic
investments in mental health
we launched the arpa H drive for
breakthrough in the fights against
cancer Alzheimer's and diabetes and so
much more
we passed
Heath Robbins
Robinson act named after the late Iraq
war veteran whose story about exposure
to toxic burn kids I shared here last
year
I understand something about those burn
pits but there's so much more to do
we can do it together
join us tonight is a father named Doug
from Newton New Hampshire
hero Jill my wife a letter and me as
well
about his courageous daughter Courtney
a contagious laugh
his sister's best friend her sister's
best friend
he shared the story all too familiar to
millions of Americans and many of you in
the audience
Courtney discovered pills in high school
it spiraled into addiction
and eventually death from a fentanyl
overdose
she's just 20 years old
described in the last eight years
without her Doug said
there's no worse pain
if their families turn pain to purpose
working to end the stigma and change
laws
he told us he wants to start a journey
toward American Recovery
Doug we're with you
fentanyl is killing more than 70 000
Americans a year
[Applause]
you got it
so let's launch a major surge to stop
fentanyl production in the sale and
trafficking with more drug detection
machines inspection cargo stop pills and
powder at the border
working with Currys like FedEx to
inspect more packages for drugs
strong penalties to crack down on
fentanyl traffic
let's do more mental health especially
for our children
when millions of young people are
struggling with bullying violence trauma
we're in greater access to mental health
care to schools
we must finally hold social media
companies accountable for experimenting
or doing running children for profit
there's time to pass bipartisan
reservation to stop big Tech from
collecting personal data on our kids and
teenagers online
fade targeted advertising their children
and improve stricter limits on the
personal data that companies collect on
all of this
third
less than more to keep this nation's
ones fully sacred obligation
equip those we send into Harm's Way and
care for them and their families when
they come home
job training job placement for veterans
and their spouses as they come to return
to civilian life helping veterans afford
the rent because no one should be
homeless in America especially someone
who served the country
foreign
we had our first real discussion asked
him to take the job I'm glad he did
we were losing up to 25 veterans a day
on suicide
now we're losing 17 today to the silent
scourge of suicide 17 veterans a day
are committing suicide
more than all the people being killed in
the wars
folks
VA is doing everything he can including
expanding mental health screening
proven programs of recruits veterans to
help other veterans understand what
they're going through
get them the help they need
we got to do more
and fourth
last year Jill and I reignited the
cancer moonshot
that I was able to start with President
Obama asked me to lead our
Administration on this issue
our goal is to cut the cancer death
rates
at least by 50 in the next 25 years
turn more Cancers and death sentences to
treatable diseases
provide more support for patients and
their families
it's personal to so many of us so many
of us in this audience
joining us
are Morris and Candice
an Irishman and a daughter of immigrants
from Panama
they met and fell in love in New York
City and got married in the same Chapel
Jill and I got married in New York City
Kindred Spirits he wrote us a letter
about his little daughter Ava
and I saw her just before I came over
she was just a year old when she was
diagnosed with rare kidney disease
cancer
after 26 blood transfusions
11 rounds of radiation eight rounds of
quinoa chemo
one kidney removed
give it a five percent survival rate
he wrote how in the darkest moments he
thought if she goes I can't stay
many of you have been through that as
well
children understand that like so many of
you
he read Jill's book describing our
family's cancer Journey
and how we try to steal moments of Joy
where we could with both
for them that glimmer of Joy was the
half smile
of their baby girl
not everything
they never gave up hope
little Ava never gave up hope
she turns four next month
they just found out
see the odds is on her way to make cure
to cancer
and she's watching from the White House
tonight if she's not asleep already
for the lives we can save
[Applause]
for the lives we could say in the lives
we've lost
let this be a truly American moment that
rallies the country and the world
together
and prove that we can still do big
things
20 years ago into the leadership of
President Bush
and countless Advocates and champions he
undertook a bipartisan effort through
pepfar to transform the global fight
against HIV AIDS it's been a huge
success who thought big and thought
large he moved
I believe we can do the same thing with
cancer
[Applause]
let's end cancer as we know it
sure some cancers
once and for all
folks
there's one reason why we've been able
to do all these things
our democracy itself
it's the most fundamental thing of all
with democracy everything's possible
without it nothing is
the last few years our democracy has
been threatened and attacked put at risk
put to the test this very room on
January the 6th
and then just a few months ago
an unhinged big lie
a sale and Unleashed a political
violence the home of the then Speaker of
the House of Representatives
using the very same language the
insurrectionists used as they stalk
these Halls Enchanted on January 6th
here tonight in this chamber is a man
who Bears the scars of that brutal
attack
but it's as tough and as strong as
resilient as they get my friend Paul
Pelosi Boston
foreign
[Applause]
Must ALL speak out
there's no place for political violence
in America we have to protect the right
to vote not suppress the fat fundamental
right honor the results of our elections
not subvert the will of people we have
to uphold the rule of law and restore
trusting our institutions of democracy
and we must give hate and extremism in
any form no Safe Harbor
democracy
must not be a partisan issue
it's an American issue
[Applause]
every generation American has faced a
moment where they haven't been called to
protect our democracy defend and stand
up for it
and this is our moment
my fellow Americans
we meet tonight at an inflection point
one of those moments
than only a few Generations ever face
with the direction
we now take is going to decide the
course of this nation for decades to
come
we're not bystanders of History
we're not powerless before the forces
that confront us
it's within our power of We the People
we're facing the test of our time
we have to be the nation we've always
been at our best optimistic hopeful
forward-looking a nation that breaks his
light over dark
hope over fear you never do the
stability over chaos
we have to see each other not as enemies
but as fellow Americans
we're good people
the only nation in the world built on an
idea the only one
other nations
are defined by geography ethnicity
[Applause]
but we're the only nation based on an
idea
that all of us
every one of us is created equal in the
image of God
a nation that stands as a beacon of the
world
a nation
in a new age of possibilities
so I've come to fulfill my
constitutional obligation to report in
the state of the union and here's a
reminder of my report
because the soul of this nation is
strong
because the backboken backbone of this
nation is strong because the people of
this nation are strong the state of the
union is strong
[Applause]
I'm not new to this place I stand in the
night having served as long as about any
one of you who've ever served here
but I've never been more optimistic
about our future about the future
America just to remember who we are
we're the United States of America and
there's nothing nothing beyond our
capacity if we do it together God bless
you all may God protect our truth
thank you
you're watching their English where
President Joe Biden is addressed
a joint house of Congress in the state
of the union he was
presenting for at least an hour and 20
minutes let's cross over to Kimberley
Health Kimberly you've been obviously
assessing exactly what the president
said he touched on what would have been
a very domestic agenda to start with
everything from employment to political
infighting manufacturing federal debt
Health Care big Pharma taxes he was
obviously appealing to the domestic
audience but it had a touch of
bipartisan approach everywhere with the
phrase let's get the job done
yeah and
like what was
the beach was a moment kind of in the
center of the speech there something
that you really don't see often in
Washington that it was when the
president broke away from his prepared
remarks and began negotiating live in
the middle of his speech with opposition
Republicans it was a remarkable moment
what he was doing there was really
talking and showing his skills as
someone who's been in Washington for
decades not only as a president as a
vice president but also as a member of
Congress the issue is somewhat
complicated it's about raising the debt
limit in the United States so that it
can pay for social programs like
Medicare and Social Security these are
government programs to help the elderly
and and those in the United States that
need kind of a step up and and help and
right now many Republicans that's the
opposition party of the debt president's
Democratic party are opposed to raising
this limit and so you heard there's some
pushback in the middle of the speech as
the president was making that case so he
turned his body and said let's stand up
for seniors and he got this rare moment
of sort of unanimity you saw the
president saying that's something we all
can agree on and he delivered on a
campaign promise right there in the
middle of his speech it showed his
skills as a statement and it really
showed that he was able to deliver on a
campaign promise that honestly up until
now he has not been able to deliver on
he campaigned that he said look I have
the experience I have the ability to
unite this divided America and up until
now there's been a lot of skepticism
that he's been able to do that but there
in live television he delivered on that
and it really was remarkable to see that
moment even as his critics were
challenging him yelling liar you saw
both sides standing up both Republicans
and Democrats and it really was kind of
the highlight of the speech sure there
were other great moments for the
president but that is the one that is
likely to capture headlines and I can
tell you in covering many state of the
unions as a reporter in Washington it's
not something that I've ever seen before
where you've sort of seen these two
party is coming together negotiating
over legislation in the middle of a
State of the Union Address it was really
quite remarkable
Kimberly held it there our White House
correspondent thanks Kimberly of course
we'll be unpicking exactly uh what the
president's been saying I'm sure
throughout the day but let's cross over
now to our Washington broadcast Center
where we're joined by Republican
strategist John Theory and he's
alongside Democratic strategist Amisha
cross a fellow at the Truman National
Security project let's talk to Amisha
Fitz good to have you both on the
program and thanks for joining us on Al
Jazeera and Misha just your initial
reaction to What would I would describe
as a very animated and very forthright
president who is making his agenda and
policy very clear for the American
public
for anyone who wasn't a
please carry on Amisha we'll come to you
in a moment John
for anyone who wasn't aware of his
achievements he went down the list from
chips to infrastructure to Historic
investments in health care and reducing
the cost of pharmaceutical drugs
particularly insulin making sure that
America gets back on track with
competitiveness in terms of student the
efforts in student loan reduction
um everything that needed to be hit on
he hit on in this speech I think in
addition to really showcasing his
prowess as a leader as a as a former
legislator as someone who understands
that room very well in getting
Republicans essentially to commit to not
gutting Social Security to not gutting
uh retirement to make sure that these
things are taken very seriously to make
sure that Medicare isn't on The Chopping
Block these are things that really
matter to the American people and they
think that President Biden fully
understood that and he wove a very very
strong tapestry of his efforts and the
Democratic party's efforts in ensuring
that America gets back on track
let me just jump in there how difficult
do you think it's going to be for him to
navigate State away from the cameras
behind closed doors because what said in
public is often very difficult to
negotiate even when you're trying to get
bipartisan approaches to to most things
he did talk about the infrastructure
project and the bridge in Kentucky which
was very popular uh uh bipartisan
approach and something that both Mitch
McConnell was very agreeable too but
that's just one incident isn't it
absolutely and a slim slim majority for
republicans in the house it's still a
majority for republicans in the house
there is an uphill battle that this
President is going to have in getting
certain things passed I think that that
is widely acknowledged particularly
because Republicans are more interested
in fighting culture wars in the
animation we've seen across several
States and in quite frankly moving away
from what the American public actually
wants to see in terms of legislative
change but Joe Biden has worked in this
type of environment before he's the
strongest in terms of building allies
particularly those from and he only
needs a handful from across the other
side of the aisle I think he's going to
get the job done okay let's cross over
to John John let me just get your
initial impressions of what you thought
obviously many Republicans wouldn't have
agreed with much of what President Biden
has achieved would you agree or disagree
you know what I was struck by the speech
was it was kind of a return to normalcy
it's been a long time since we've had
kind of a normal State of the Union
Address where people we were in a post
covet world where there was elements
from Bill Clinton where he had a bunch
of small things that he want to talk
about like getting rid of junk fees he
was at many at times bipartisan where he
was trying to you know congratulate both
Mitch McConnell and Kevin McCarthy I
think there was a very strong elements
for the president there were other other
elements where Republicans would have
you know appreciated you know this whole
straw man out there that the Republicans
were going to you know slash Social
Security or Medicare they never were
going to do that they don't have the
votes to do that they don't want to do
that Donald Trump certainly didn't want
to do that uh there was other things
that he you know sounded a little bit
like Donald Trump like we gotta you know
get the Border enforced we need to do
this something with fentanyl we need to
stand up to China that sounds a little
trumpian to me and then there were
things that he had to you know really
kind of lay the base and be with the
base that you know Democrats liked and
Republicans didn't like so there was a
big as a long speech it was not unusual
for a state of the union they they had a
lot of different elements to it yeah I
think the speech was better written and
delivered I think he really hurried
through the speech we thank God because
it was still an hour and 20 minutes yeah
so you know if I think that like Most
states the union was It was kind of
effective okay let's just take one of
the subjects which is the economy it's
something that obviously resonates
across the board uh whether you're a
Democrat or a Republican and John can I
just ask you about the the issues of the
economy when it comes to investment in
America First making things in America
do you think that's going to resonate
with the public large across the U.S and
is this going to impress them because
State of the Union is obviously you
might say a fundamental foundation for
laying the groundwork should he want to
as he says want to run for the
presidency again
well you know I think that this is also
an element that Donald Trump talked
about which was we need to have all
these products made in America you know
it sounds really good in in you know
when you talked about the rhetoric it
does add a lot of costs to all of your
government spending
um so they're you know the worldwide
global economy has done a wonderful job
of keeping prices low for American
consumers uh so there's a there's a
choice you have to make do you want to
increase the cost of products and have
them all made in America or do you want
to buy this the cheapest products
elsewhere and so you know I think the
president was saying you know something
that sounds very good for the average
American voter but for the average
American Consumer it's going to be much
more costly uh Misha we're just coming
near to the end of the program so just
very quickly he did touch upon the whole
drug problem across the U.S with various
people and families in the gallery
looking at what's going on how how
problematic is this for any
Administration in the White House to
deal with the issue of drug abuse
well the rising crisis of opioid use and
opioid abuse is is something that we
have dealt with now for close to a
decade and I think that the the
president put a eye on it that needs to
be there in terms of attention when it
comes to reduction there needs to be
more more clinics more availability and
affordability for those who need help to
get that help in addition to health care
that allows for those who aren't just at
the top when it comes to wealth but also
those who are in poverty to be able to
access that help and honestly I would
hope that this extends beyond the opioid
crisis but also to individuals who have
been addicted to things like crack
cocaine where we know that the response
particularly as it relates to drug abuse
has been vastly different when you look
at drug abuse and the the method that is
being used now when a lot of the abusers
are typically white Americans versus
historically how this has been treated
when those have been when the victims
have been people of color
Amisha it's interesting to get your uh
context and your analysis as well as
John free thanks so much for both of you
joining us here on Al Jazeera
and of course we'll leave you with some
of the pictures and images of President
Biden uh finalizing and saying goodbye
to the various politicians in Congress
as he delivered his State of the Union
Address we'll have more on this
throughout the day stay with us here on
Al Jazeera